c'est un nouvel écrin de la culture à
bourges qui doit ouvrir ses portes en
septembre prochain
trois mille mètres carrés de surfaces
dédiées à l'expression artistique sous
toutes ses formes mais également à la
création
nous sommes dans la salle de répétition
qui est vraiment comme vous le voyez
magnifique plancher de danse bon les
miroirs ne sont pas encore là mais on
pourra accueillir des danseurs
effectivement qui travaillent du théâtre
de la musique
le complexe disposera de deux salles de
cinéma et deux salles de spectacle la
plus grande
baptisé du nom d'une personnalité de
bouche quand on est sur le plateau bien
sûr c'est impressionnant mais vous avez
vu la pente est forte donc on a réussi
enfin les architectes ont réussi à
concevoir une salle de 700 places qui
restent on va dire intime ce qui
manquait en fait à cette ville c'est un
une maison de la culture une scène
nationale qui soit un outil pour
aujourd'hui d'accueillir toute la
création européenne mondiale maison de
la culture printemps de bourges école
nationale supérieure d'arts friche
artistique autant d'atouts que la ville
compte mettre en avant pour rafler le
titre de capitale française de la
culture à la clé un million d'euros de
financement pour l'organisation
d'événements bonjour les capacités
d'accueil aujourd'hui en matière
hôtelière pour accueillir des visiteurs
venant de toute la france et pourquoi
pas d'europe autour de ces
manifestations dont nous sommes dans le
sud une région ou bien ce sud et à feu
un peu marginalisé par moment on est un
peu dans ce qu'on appelle la france
périphérique donc on a besoin de ce
financement pour je dirais redonner de
l'attractivité notre territoire
à l'issue d'une première sélection début
février
dix villes candidates seront retenues
avant l'annoncé du lauréat d'ici fin
mars